breaking news dramatische informationen
über die opfer das tote opfer die frau
ist offenbar nach unseren informationen
lehrerin unter den verletzten befinden
sich auch angehörige einer schülergruppe
offenbar schüler eben dieser lehrerin
das deckt sich auch mit
augenzeugenberichten die sagten der
fahrer sei mitten in eine schülergruppe
von schülern im teenager-alter gefahren
und wir wissen jetzt die tote person
dabei soll es sich um die lehrerin der
schülergruppe handeln sie wurde noch vor
ort versucht zu reanimieren
das ist trauriger weise gescheitert dort
also das auto in eine schülergruppe
gerast wir haben auch meldungen von
einem verletzten mädchen 16 jahre alt
sie eine fraktur rund um das becken
haben soll so berichten es augenzeugen
und auch retter also es scheint sich die
scheinen sich die informationen zu
verdichten dass eine schülergruppe dort
involviert gewesen sein muss ja und wir
sprechen jetzt mit florian hartwig der
uns zugeschaltet ist er ist politik und
terrorismus wissenschaftler er hat wie
sie haben jetzt die ganzen aktuellen
informationen mitbekommen wir wissen im
moment noch nicht ob es eben ein
anschlag oder ein unfall war wie
bewerten sie die situation mit den
informationen die wir bisher haben ja
vielen dank erstmal natürlich als
gewaltakt
eines einzeltäters offenbar zumindest
eines einzeltäters in der tat ausführung
das ist auch ein trend in der jüngsten
zeit auch gerade bei menschen die sich
online radikalisieren dass sie eben
alleine losschlagen können jetzt gibt
insgesamt drei möglichkeiten die ich
jetzt sehe zum einen dass es sich um
eine amoktat handelt eines psychisch
gestörten da gab es immer wieder auch
beispiele auch in deutschland in den
letzten jahren zum beispiel auch in
münster bei einigen jahren zum zweiten
könnte sich es sich um rechten terror
zum beispiel handeln da gibt es momentan
auch eine gewaltwelle wie wir wissen aus
buffalo zuletzt oder eben auch aus halle
und hanau und zum dritten und da kommen
natürlich auch an den ort des geschehens
leider muss man sagen berliner
breitscheidplatz
weihnachtsmarkt 2016 das islamistisch
motiviert sein kann aber insgesamt ist
natürlich der fall so der täter wollte
fliehen die frage ist auch noch was es
eben auch mit dem mit der opfer aus was
zu tun hat sie haben das ja angesprochen
auch mit einer schülerklasse aber sobald
wir mehr wissen auch über die identität
des täters desto besser kann man den
fall dann auch zu ordnen da sind die
ermittlungen ja derzeit noch am laufen
es ist zu diesem zeitpunkt müssen wir
nochmal ganz klar betonen noch nicht
klar ob es sich um einen unfall handelt
oder ob der mann mit vorsatz gehandelt
hat er wird derzeit von der berliner
polizei befragt welche gedanken haben
sie dazu ist es irgendwie möglich dass
man in solche vorfälle solche taten sei
es ein unfall oder sei es mit vorsatz
gehandelt möglicherweise besser
verhindern kann dass wir mehr sicherheit
schaffen immer wieder weltweit gibt es
vorfälle dieser art was kann man tun um
dem vorzubeugen um das einzudämmen ja
man kann die kurfürstenstraße nicht
blockieren man kann auch keine
weihnachtsmärkte blockieren insgesamt
ist es eben sehr schwierig was man tun
kann ist wenn es jetzt irgendwie zb
politisch motiviert war das war eben
stärker auch die prozesse sehen der
online radikalisierung wir haben ja auch
zb gesehen dass natürlich der krone
lockdown nicht für eine lok down für
extremismus gesorgt hat und dass wir
natürlich zum beispiel diese tat auch
hatten in buffalo wo der täter gesagt
hat ja was sich aus langweile
radikalisierte hat 180 seitiges manifest
hinterlassen und wir leben natürlich
auch in turbulenten zeiten jetzt auch
mit einem russischen angriffskrieg auf
der ukraine mit den folgen auf
psychologischer natur von corona und wir
müssen uns natürlich auch die frage
stellen ob es sich auch jedem um
nachahmungstaten handelt denn wir haben
ja eine gewisse weile auch der gewalt
aber solche daten lassen sich in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft in der wir
leben nicht verhindern
das ist völlig klar hundertprozentige
sicherheit
dort niemals schaffen bedauerlicherweise
helfen sie uns einmal uns mitzunehmen
und jetzt sind die arbeit der polizei
die jetzt gerade diesen mann befragen
herausfinden müssen weil es vorsatz hat
es sich um einen unfall gehandelt was
findet jetzt gerade sozusagen hinter den
kulissen statt im zuge dieser
ermittlungen
also erstens ist ja wichtig in
anführungszeichen für die aufklärung
dieser tat und das muss ja für uns alle
im vordergrund stehen dass der täter
gefasst wurde auch durch mutige
passanten einen passanten
dank uns auch mitnehmen sollte emotional
an diesem tag und jetzt ist natürlich
die frage welche identität hat der täter
ist er zum beispiel ein geflüchteter ist
er ein wie alt ist er ist ein ein
schüler ist sich ja leider auch so dass
taten immer
dass die täter immer jünger werden auch
die frage ist ja sozusagen psychisch
gestört auch natürlich was sich schon
angesprochen haben war es ein unfall was
ich eher nicht denke und dann geht man
natürlich dran jetzt bei den
ermittlungen ausfindig zu machen wo hat
der täter gewohnt
was kann man eben auch herausfinden über
sein verhalten jetzt online denn wir
haben es ja leider auch mit vielen
menschen zu tun ihre zeit ausschließlich
online verbringen und da ist natürlich
die frage gibt es da irgendwelche
politischen auffälligkeiten ist
natürlich auch ganz wichtig jetzt gibt
zum beispiel auch ein manifest der täter
wollte sich offenbar nicht umbringen es
muss dabei auch zu dem jetzigen
zeitpunkt nichts heißen aber was ist
eigentlich die botschaft von dieser tat
also ist es jetzt reiner wahnsinn ist es
jetzt ein angriff auf die westliche welt
der freiheit
ist es eben wie gesagt die tat eines
psychisch gestörten oder steckt irgendwo
auch eine politische botschaft dahinter
die zb rechtsterroristische aber eben
auch islamistisch motiviert sein können
das sind die fragen die die ermittler
jetzt sich stellen müssen und die wir
auch abwarten müssen um dann auch ein
urteil treffen zu können denn dieses
urteil kann man seriöserweise zu diesem
zeitpunkt nicht treffen das einzige was
ich jetzt sagen kann ist dass es ein
brutaler gewalt zwar mitten am tag in
einer zeit wo wir uns jetzt nach der
pandemie auf einen schönen sommer freuen
und das natürlich auch eine gewisse
verknüpfung tragische art vorliegt
einfach durch den anschlagsort
einfach auch durch die erinnerung auch
an
den islamistisch motivierten anschlag im
weihnachtsmarkt in berlin 2016
zeitschriften genau gegenüber von dieser
jetzigen unglücksstelle im passiert ist
vielen dank florian hartleb für diese
aktuellen einschätzung zu diesem vorfall
hier jetzt gerade vor wenigen stunden in
berlin am kudamm und ich gebe jetzt
einmal rüber zu patricia die nämlich
einmal diesen unfallhergang beschreiben
soll
ja wir versuchen nicht hier jetzt anhand
dieser karte die puzzleteile einmal ein
bisschen mehr zusammenzusetzen und
nachzuvollziehen welche route der fahrer
zurückgelegt hat er mittlerweile von der
polizei festgenommen und derzeit verhört
wird schauen wir uns das mal ganz genau
an dass hier das zentrum von berlin
mitten im zentrum des herzens von
berlins und sie sehen hier den
breitscheidplatz
2016 dort wir erinnern uns
2016 dort am weihnachtsmarkt der tourist
anis amri der dort zwölf menschen tötete
in dem er mit einem lkw dort hinein fuhr
und dort nahm offenbar diese vater
nieren start und sie sehen hier lauter
geschäfte die vielfach besucht sind von
till von touristen davon aber auch
berlinern das ist eine prachtstraße hier
in berlin und dort bretterte der fahrer
dann offenbar mit erhöhter
geschwindigkeit augenzeugen haben uns
berichtet dass sie schätzen dass er
teilweise mit bis zu 150 km/h dort
unterwegs gewesen sein da am markt
rettete hier entlang schießt dann
offenbar hier auf eine menschenmenge
dort verdichten sich derzeit die
informationen dass es sich um eine
schülergruppe handeln könnte denn die
tote person dann hier in der mitte der
straße soll die lehrerin dieser
schülergruppe gewesen sein es soll auch
verletzte schüler die rede ist
beispielsweise von einem 16 jahre alten
mädchen das einen bruch an der hüfte
erlitten hat also hier ist das ungefähr
passiert dann ging es über über die
straße dann aber wieder zurück hier dann
auf den bürgersteig und dann hier dort
dass das foto entstanden dass wir ihnen
auch schon zeigen dass sie jetzt auch
hier gerade in split kann ich gerade
sehen sehen wird es der wagen dann zum
stehen gekommen es handelt sich um einen
kleinwagen um einen silbergrauen renault
clio dann hier zum stehen gekommen und
sie sehen das ganze spielt sich ab
ganzen welt beispielsweise hier das
kadewe ganz beliebter ort hier in berlin
in der hauptstadt für touristen für
berliner und hier kam das auto zum
stehen es können sie dann oben hier
erkennen dort bretterte es ins
schaufenster einer douglas filiale rein
und dort konnten mutige passanten den
fahrer aufhalten der offenbar so sagen
uns augenzeugen versuchte wegzurennen
und passanten konnten den mann
festhalten bis die polizei eingetroffen
ist und derzeit soll er dort von der
polizei jetzt verhört werden wir haben
ihnen eben gerade im zuge dieser sendung
auch erste fotos von der festnahme
gezeigt dass also die strecke es soll
sich um etwa 200 meter handeln die der
fahrer hier zurücklegte ein mensch ist
dabei gestorben offenbar die lehrerin
einer schülergruppe zahlreiche menschen
sind verletzt worden mindestens zwölf so
gerade die angaben der berliner
feuerwehr und der polizei
darunter auch schwerverletzte und
darunter auch menschen die derzeit noch
um ihr leben kämpfen und unsere reporter
sind natürlich hier genau an dieser
stelle wo sich das heute früh um 10 uhr
30 abgespielt hat mit ihnen wollen wir
jetzt sprechen sie sprechen mit
zahlreichen augenzeugen mit erst rettern
und auch mit der biene berliner polizei
und der feuerwehr und dazu gebe ich
jetzt zurück zu meiner kollegin kyra
ordnern
ja vielen dank patricia und wir müssen
auch einmal auf diese fotos eingehen die
wir ihnen gerade von der festnahme von
vor ort gezeigt haben dort wurde eben
einen mann festgenommen an diesem
unglücksort dort am berliner kudamm wir
müssen aber einmal dazu sagen wir können
nicht zu 100 prozent ich sagen das ist
der fahrer dieses dieses autos war das
eben jetzt im moment in dieser douglas
filiale das im moment in diese douglas
filiale gekracht ist sondern es ist auf
jeden fall aber ein mann der amt tatort
festgenommen wurde ob es der fahrer war
oder nicht dazu gibt es noch keine
genauen angaben weil sobald wir
genaueres wissen werden wir sie darüber
natürlich informieren es gibt nämlich
auch ein video das wir ihnen in kurzen
moment den wenigen momenten zeigen
werden eben von dieser festnahme wo wir
dann nochmal einmal sehen wie dieser
mann dort festgenommen wurde es ist
natürlich ein
es ist ein mann eben der dort
festgenommen wurde er trägt rote
turnschuhe eine jogginghose und war auf
jeden fall bei bewusstsein als er
ebendort von den polizisten festgenommen
wurde aber ob es der wirkliche fahrer
ist das können wir noch nicht zu 100
prozent sagen da bleiben wir natürlich
dran und sobald wir da eine bestätigung
haben werden wir ihnen das natürlich
nochmal nachreichen liebe zuschauerin
und zuschauer fest steht aber dieser
mann wird gerade wegen dieses vorfalls
von der polizei verhört
dementsprechend bleiben wir da natürlich
dran und werden ihn auch gleich in
wenigen minuten das video von der
festnahme zeigen jetzt sprechen wir
einmal mit unseren reportern die vor ort
sind die dort recherchieren die dort mit
augenzeugen sprechen und natürlich auch
mit den beamten vor ort wir sprechen
unter anderem mit annika rage mit hannes
grafik mit isabel pfannkuche und mit til
biermann annika zuerst zu dir wie es bei
dir vor ort die aktuelle situation wo
stehst du und was hast du dort sehen
können
[Musik]
genau ich stehe gerade hinterm ihr seht
ihr das zumindest da liegt eben diese
eine
tote bei der sich wohl nach unseren
erkenntnissen um eine lehrerin handeln
soll da übernimmt die polizei gerade
eben die beweise auf später wird dann
die leiche auch abtransportiert deshalb
sieht man eben auch dass hier gerade
alles abgehangen wurde das natürlich
auch ein sichtschutz besteht und eben
die leute und die passanten die eben
noch überall langgehen nichts von diesen
schrecklichen bildern sehen wir können
jetzt einmal noch mal nach rechts
schwingen schwenken da seht ihr auch
noch wie viele einsatzkräfte vor ort
sind hinter den
feuerwehrautos sehen wir ganz viele sind
ganz viele rettungskräfte die sich eben
gerade auch noch erholen weil hier
gerade ein bisschen mehr ruhe eingekehrt
ist wenn man das so sagen darf obwohl
natürlich noch alles unklar ist und wenn
wir nachher schwenken dass es eben diese
route um die es ging und eben 200 meter
weiter ist der genannte douglas den wir
eben auch noch mal im video gesehen
haben in denen dann eben dieser renault
clio dann zum stehen kam
eine garage vielen herzlichen dank und
wir gehen weiter zu til biermann tvs mit
augenzeugen und augenzeugen sprechen
können und die hinweise verdichten sich
dass eine schülergruppe in diesem
vorfall involviert war was kannst du uns
darüber sagen
ja das ist genau das was mir eine frau
vor hunderte die weinen an einer wand
saß genau neben den absperrungen die
sagte da waren kinder elf- bis
15-jährige schüler und ja wie du sagst
es hat sich das jetzt offenbar bestätigt
leider
zu tode gekommen ist und ja ich stehe
ich auf dem breitscheidplatz
an den treppen noch fotos stehen der
opfer des anschlags damals und er sollte
das jetzt wieder ein anschlag gewesen
sein wäre das natürlich schrecklich
genau an diesem ort ist sowieso
schrecklich aber dann noch an diesem ort
der sowieso schon so viel leid über
familien und menschen brachte und ja
also es ist ein riesiges presseaufgebot
hier das kann ich mal kurz zeigen das
ist natürlich fernsehsender aus aller
herren länder hier
unterrichten darüber was hier passiert
ist und ja sollte es ein anschlag
gewesen sein
muss ich sagen das ist eigentlich
erstaunlich finde wenn es wenn es nur in
anführungsstrichen ein opfer wäre wenn
man sich erinnert an nizza wo ein lkw
stand promenade entlang gerast
aber wie wir schon gesagt haben wir
wissen nicht was dahinter steckt
das ist das was ich jetzt hier so sagen
danke für diese eindrücke und für diese
schilderung von den augenzeugen wir
machen weiter bei handelsweg handels wie
hast du das gefühl ist diese situation
der mittlerweile unter kontrolle sind
dort genug rettungskräfte auch vor ort
um eben diese ganzen verletzten und auch
die augenzeugen zu betreuen
die situation ist meines erachtens jetzt
hier völlig unter kontrolle
die verletzten sind abtransportiert
hierbei eine
kranken sammelstelle passierten damals
stelle eingerichtet von der berliner
polizei die es mittlerweile aufgelöst
worden die rettungswagen sind weg die
rüstwagen aber das ganze equipment
wieder eingeräumt transportiert wieder
ab dass offiziere und wieder einsetzbar
gemacht sondern mit zwei augenzeugen
hier auf der ecke an der rankestraße
gesprochen bei gastronomen der eine saß
gerade draußen im außenbereich seiner
wirtschaft bisher ein seltsames geräusch
das beschrieben gehört hat dann also
richtung kurfürstendamm geschaut hinter
diesem imbiss und hat einen knall gehört
hat uns sofort schreie gehört und hat
eben eher seltsam gesehen wie die
menschen umgefallen sind da konnte sich
das erst mal so gar nicht erklären es
hin gerannt und hat dann sofort letzter
auf den bürgersteig gesehen ein junges
mädchen am warmen bein verletzt zu haben
es beschrieben hat sich um die kleine
gekümmert
dann hat ja eine weitere person gesehen
beschrieb mir dass sie eben im
bauchbereich blutverschmiert war und hat
versucht so gut es ging um erste hilfe
zu leisten hat wie die personen in
stabile seitenlage gebracht hat dann den
notruf gewählt 112 der werdauer besetzt
zu beschrieb es wer war dann selber
extrem aufgewühlt und die haben eben
gesagt das fahrzeug konnte er selber
nicht mehr sehen weil das ich eben die
verletzten personen auch zu wenig
gekümmert hat und hat aber eben gehört
wie es deutlich weiter in richtung
tausendfach gestand die zuglast finali
eine filiale in das schaufenster
gefahren ist den täter konnte er nicht
sehen aber erst geschrieben geschrieben
dass das auto mit einer sehr hohen
geschwindigkeit eben hier unterwegs war
und ja er hat eben auch gesagt dass er
den anschlag am breitscheidplatz am
weihnachtsmarkt damals miterlebt hat und
gesagt hat jetzt kommt eben alles wieder
einigen wochen aber extrem betroffen
ansonsten ist die situation aber meines
erachtens unter kontrolle die polizei
ging es nach wie vor gut präsent sehr
präsent eben auch nicht im
ausserordentlichen geräten mit
maschinenpistolen die sieht man hier mit
praktischen helmen das ist eben nicht
die normale schutzpolizei die wir so
kennen aus dem normalen straßenbild aus
dem alltag sondern es sind eben wirklich
immer stärker bewaffnete einheiten und
die jetzt aber auch langsam runter
fahren die absperrungen sind noch groß
und wir haben gerade gesehen wie ein
anderer gastronom hier ein kasten
softdrinks an die beamten ausgeteilt hat
die natürlich auch in der sonne stehen
und gesagt habe heute wir brauchen alles
wir brauchen unsere polizei ihr seid für
uns da ihr schützt uns und das ist
natürlich eine tolle
solidaritätskundgebung praktisch von
diesen menschen die froh sind dass die
polizei hier für schutz und ordnung
sorgt und sich eben darum kümmert und
versucht herauszubekommen was die
ursache für diese katastrophe hier heute
berlin war vielen dank an es für deine
eindrücke und jetzt wollen wir auch noch
einmal sprechen mit unserer reporterin
isabel van kuche isabel de was ja auch
eine der ersten die dort eben vor ort
mit zeugen sprechen konnte was haben sie
dir erzählt
genau hier wo ich gerade stehe habe ich
heute morgen relativ wird nach diesem
unfall eben mit einem zeugen gestört er
war ein erntehelfer also er hat noch
versucht den nach unseren informationen
die lehrerin zu reanimieren das hat
leider nicht mehr geklappt es war alle
hilfe kam zu spät gibt es leider
verstorben und er hat auch den unfall
beobachtet und zwar sieht man jetzt hier
direkt hinter mir diese die preisspirale
dieses runde gebäude daneben
stand und genau dort ist eben der
unfallfahrer auf den bürgersteig auf
gefahren dort wurden auch die meisten
leute verletzt und sitzen ja auch
teilweise immer noch verletzt da oder
dort sind auch immer noch menschen die
unter schock stehen und beinen
sportsitzen und dann ist er eben weiter
gefahren hinter mir entlang sozusagen
dort ist dann die rankestraße dass er
über gefahren und kam dann wieder auf
den bürgersteig und da ist dann eben der
ersthelfer eingesprungen und hat
versucht dort frau zu reanimieren
ansonsten ist aber auch bei dieser
lieber filiale habe ich mit einem mann
gesprochen der kurz nachdem der fahrer
wirklich dort entlang gefahren ist also
das auto noch hinter sich gesehen
ist er dort entlang gekommen und hat es
ist noch beiseite gesprungen ist dann
schnell in ein cafe geflüchtet was eben
dort direkt auch ist und er meinte
wirklich dass dieser fahrer gezielt jagd
auf passanten gemacht hat und dass er
auch noch mal auf das gaspedal gedrückt
hätte so wie es eben von anderen
augenzeugen auch schon beschrieben wurde
dass er wirklich vollgas gegeben hat und
dort entlang groß ist wirklich
erschreckende eindrücke die uns da von
augenzeugen berichtet werden vielen dank
an unsere reporter vor ort ihr bleibt
natürlich dort um weiter über diese
geschehnisse ein überblick zu behalten
danke an euch für diesen moment